exige une de la région et
l'envasement de David et
économie de la région.
- Tu peux les garder
deux jours ou frigo,
sinon tu les congèles, puis...
- Il y a cinq ans, Léa St-Lo
a choisi d'ouvrir son commerce
en plein coeur de Rouyn-Noranda.
Aujourd'hui, elle se range
aux côtés des dizaines
d'entrepreneurs locaux qui
soutiennent que la crise de la
qualité de l'air nuit à leurs
efforts de développement,
de recrutement et de rétention
de la main-d'oeuvre.
Si plus d'une centaine ont
accepté de signer le mémoire
déposé jeudi, seulement
66 d'e e e eux ont accepté
de le faire publiquement.
Ceux qui préféraient rester
anonyme disent le faire
par crainte d'en subir
les contrecoups.
LÉA ST-LOUIS, propriétaire,chchk
- Non, je ne dirais pas
que j'ai peur.
Comme je disais, c'est...
si ça a lieu d'être négatif
pour moi, rendu là,
je regarderai ce que je ferai,
mais je pense que c'est :
la santé et l'environnement
sont trop importants
pour avoir peur d'en parler.
- Patrick Rannou, qui est
propriétaire d'une boutique
spécialisée dans la vente
de produits électroniques,
a quant à lui hésité
à s'afficher publiquement
en désaccord avec le plan
proposé par la Fonderie Horne.
Il espère toutefois que la voix
commune du groupe etetettra
de revoir l'argument économique
dans ce dossier.
PATRICK RANNOU, entrepreneur
- Il y a quand même un autre
volet économique de la ville
qui est aussi inquiet
si on laisse aller ça
de cette façon-là, par rapport à
l'image de la ville, par rapport
à l'attraction de nouxxx
employés, par rapport
à la rétention des personnes
qui vont vouloir partir.
- Bien qu'elle dit comprendre
la position durororoupement,
la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de Rouyn-Noranda
réaffirme plutôt sa confiance
envers l'entreprise
dans sonprprpre mémoire.
JEAN-CLAUDE LORANGER, membre CA,
Chambre de commerce, R.-Noranda
- La Fonderie Horne
a une importance économique
mae.e.e. On exclut la fermeture
dans notre... après avoir sondé
nos membres. Nos membres
nous disent : il ne faut pas
font fermer la fonderie,
ça a une importance stratégique.
- Les consultations publiques
sont maintenant terminées
dans ce dossier, mais
plusieurs citoyens craignent
que leur message ne soit perdu,
puisque le sous-ministre
à l'Environntntnt, Marc Croteau,
qui était d'ailleurs
à Rouyn-Noranda cette semaine,
a été remplacé.
Ici Guillaume Renaud,
Radio-Canada, Rouorororanda